in the last hour it's been announced the
2030 asian games will be held in
doha the qatari capital was revealed as
the venue by the olympic council of asia
while riyadh was named as the host of
the 2034 games
under a compromise agreed between qatar
and saudi arabia
the games are the second biggest
multi-sport event after the olympics
let's get more now with our sports
presenter andy richardson andy so both
countries had wanted to host in 2030.
how was the solution reached
well i think uh it's a victory really
for for doha and qatar's long-term
commitment to its sporting
infrastructure i mean it's
it's hard of course and not to see that
the geopolitics of this situation with
saudi arabia being part of the blockade
that's been imposed on qatar but i think
this is slightly more nuanced and
perhaps slightly more straightforward
than that qatar has vast experience of
hosting
uh huge sporting events it started
really in 2006 when it hosted the asian
games
for the first time it's remodeled its
national stadium
and everything really is in place to
re-host an asian games and since then
last year we saw the world athletics
championships hosted
here in doha and of course the big one
coming around the corner the football
world cup and that has resulted in
even more investment in training
facilities
in uh transport facilities for for fans
and media
so it's already there and the scale of
this event is hard to understate
it is the second biggest multi-sport
event after the olympics it will involve
ten thousand plus athletes um and the
olympics uh the olympic association uh
at both regional level and the
international level
by thomas back is it pains to stress
that it doesn't want to overburden
hosting countries and at the moment
qatar is in a position
where pretty much tomorrow it could host
these asian games
has to be said that riyadh and saudi
arabia are also moving in that direction
they are starting to host big sporting
events be it
a formula one race next year they've
hosted uh big boxing matches in the last
few months as well but in terms of
hosting multi-sport events with
large numbers of international athletes
it isn't quite there yet so
this compromise has been reached whereby
saudi arabia will be given that extra
few years to prepare for the 2034 asian
games
you sort of touched on it there andy but
i'm wondering if you can talk to us a
little bit more
about the wider context here
yeah of course um there is uh the the
blockade that's been imposed uh
on qatar by neighbouring countries
including saudi arabia is of course part
of the conversation
uh that's in the background here and
it's arguable that perhaps uh rihanna
wouldn't have been pushed into
into bidding so soon for an asian games
had it not been for the fact that their
their great regional rivals doha were
also going for the
for the 20 30 games there's also um a
desire to to bring the olympics one day
um to the middle east and and which
country will be at the front of the race
to do that
now doha is is very keen and to uh to
put itself forward
for 2032. um it's bid a couple of times
in the past
um the big stumbling block it will face
is
is the timing of the olympics with the
asian games
uh the organizers can be a bit more
flexible for example when doha hosted
in 2006 the games were hosted in
december
um when the weather is is much cooler
here um the olympics
they are very sort of determined to
always have the olympics hosted
june july august number of reasons for
that one of the main reasons being that
the main
source of income for the olympics um is
a huge contract they have with nbc
in the united states uh they want the
games to be hosted
in the summer they don't want it to be
clashing with major north american
sporting leagues later on in the year
when the middle east
would like to host an olympics be in
october november december but the ioc
the international olympic committee
had indicated they wanted to see doha
host another big
sporting event after the world cup
something like the asian games before
they rebid
for the olympics so this is the perfect
opportunity for that
what doha wants is some kind of
commitment that there is some
wiggle room as to when they can host the
olympics um but 2032 is a very realistic
bid
bid schedule now for doha to try and
bring the olympics to the middle east
for the first time as well
okay thank you for that sports presenter
andy richardson